good morning John so now that we've been
regularly photographing the Earth from
space for decades we can watch in like
time-lapse format as our planet changes
usually as we change our planet huge
scale stuff and Google has just released
a tool that makes this easy basically
you can scan around the entire world and
watch the last 25 years of life on Earth
what the world was like when I was four
versus what the world is like now so I
wanted to share some the cool things
that I found while doing that first
here's my hometown of Missoula and if
you look carefully you can see some new
neighborhoods being built in all the box
stores going in at the edge of town bit
of a small town but it has changed in
the last 25 years more interesting
probably is the amazing sprawl of
Orlando where John you and I grew only
the most fascinating bits are where
humans have had their deepest influences
America's insatiable appetite for cheap
coal to power our wonderful lifestyles
has led to a practice called mountaintop
removal mining and much of Appalachia
I've seen these pictures I've seen the
close-ups and I've seen it from
satellites but as you scroll around and
watch the last 20 years progress it is
astounding and terrifying and moving to
see the amount of destruction and of
course I know that I benefit personally
from this destruction but it is
destruction
similarly we all know that lots of the
Amazon rainforest has been cut down but
you really can't understand the depth
and the scale of it until you watch
happen and are able to move all around
Brazil and Bolivia and see how much of
those forests are gone now and then
there's the story of water which of
course more people consume more of Las
Vegas and Dubai spreading across deserts
Saudi Arabia with massive irrigation
projects making the deserts bloom inland
seas drying up either because of drought
or because of irrigation but in addition
to being terrifying occasionally it can
also be a story of recovery watching the
forests take back the land that had been
destroyed when Mount Saint Helens
erupted was particularly inspiring
though the nearby clear-cutting was not
we humans have a profound in largely
negative effect on the rest of the life
forms of the planet science has for a
long time offered us these truths up on
a platter in the form of data and number
is and statistics but we are people we
are not computers and we are not
particularly good at understanding what
all of those data and statistics really
mean and I be a better world of fall
policy was based on science but it's not
it's based on the individual decisions
and the individual feelings of
individual people like me and like you
for me watching all of this change with
a very limited span of my own life is
intense and it's moving and it's
terrifying we have learned a lot but we
haven't really acted on that learning
and maybe that's because we don't really
understand it we know the numbers but we
can't see it or we couldn't see it maybe
taking a look around the Google Earth
engine which I should say is based on
the NASA Landsat program which is
fantastic good job NASA might give us
all a better understanding of the
realities that we face and if we really
understand those things better then the
decisions we make will be better at
least one can hope so yay for Nancy yay
for Google yay for science yay for
understanding and hopefully also in the
near future yay for action John I'll see
you on Tuesday